two months on from the tunisian
president's decision to suspend
parliament and sack the prime minister
his supporters don't think he's gone far
enough thousands of people gathered in
tunis and other towns and cities to show
their support for kai
we want to deliver a word to tunisian
president
no going back now and to prosecute all
those who have committed crimes against
the people that is the first and main
demand to prosecute all those who have
done wrongdoing most of the protesters
carried banners attacking the anada
party it's the largest in parliament and
has been the most critical of the
president's power grab i mean there is
no way or no excuse for having a
dictatorship or making a coup if the
people are not happy with us then they
are more than free
to go to other elections and not to
elect us
so we cannot give an any excuse or
legitimize any
coup or any illegal actions the united
party says the recent appointment of
nigella buden as prime minister and any
government she forms can only be
legitimate if it is endorsed by
parliament
but kai saeed is ruling by decree
the president doesn't communicate easily
and he's surrounded by people who don't
have a political background anyone with
political experience is not in the
presidential circle if he won't consult
those with political experience the
future remains unclear for tunisians the
president says his decision to seize
power on july 25th was necessary to
prevent tunisia's collapse and it seemed
to have popular support but his failure
so far to offer a way out of the crisis
is strengthening the opposition to him
in a phone call with the french
president kai saeed told emmanuel macron
that a government will be formed in the
coming days and what he called a
national dialogue would follow
tunisia's treasury is running out of
money to pay salaries and meet loan
repayments it urgently needs a
government to negotiate an international
bailout
bernard smith al jazeera tunis